thirsty a worker Vaadin Stepanovich and
hundreds of his co-workers have been
protesting against the government for
weeks here outside the Parliament of
Montenegro they blame Prime Minister
Mello Duke on ovitch for the country's
widespread poverty and they hold him
responsible for election fraud
corruption and nepotism as long as this
government stays in power Montenegro
cannot be a democratic country if
nothing changes my family and I have no
choice but to leave to Khanna [ __ ]
first rose to power in 1991 he and his
party have dominated politics in the
small Balkan Republic
ever since do kana vich has been Prime
Minister and president and he's also a
businessman while he and his clan have
become multimillionaires many ordinary
citizens despair of the future the
problem is not just an economic crisis
the problem is also the lack of moral
values dollars come my government came
to power after 1990 and the collapse of
Yugoslavia and since then everything has
fallen apart
he wants to show us what he means and
takes us to the steelworks in niche he
was one of 7,000 steel workers once
employed here the Jacana vich clan
oversaw its sale far below value
kickbacks worth millions were allegedly
paid in the process and the Jacana vich
family lined their pockets the steel
workers have watched their livelihoods
be destroyed an entire industry has been
wiped out here in the region - Vanya
chala vich who heads an anti-corruption
organization the steelworks sell-off is
just one example of the government's
wheeling and dealing but few dare to
speak out if you are not supporting the
governing party if you are fighting
against corruption and organized crime
then certainly you're going to be
attacked and pressured when chawla which
went public about election fraud she
experienced firsthand the consequences
of speaking out pro-government
newspapers launched a witch-hunt against
her publishing photos designed to
undermine her credibility I believe that
it is the biggest the biggest proof that
we are seriously undermining corrupted
structures in the government and
organized crime structures which are
connected to the exactly but many of the
steel workers in new church are resigned
to their fate poverty is rampant many
now live in barracks close to the
steelworks
bribery is the only way they can come
buy a new job the situation has become
so bad that many of my former colleagues
come to me to ask for a liter of milk
otherwise they can't feed their kids a
growing number of Montenegrins are now
seeking asylum in Germany in the hope of
escaping corruption but their own
government refuses to acknowledge what's
happening I don't have any kind of
knowledge that corruption on any
criminal activities in Montenegro are
caused this phenomenal call asylum
seekers from Montenegro who are the
xylem seekers even now they are just I'm
but little bit poor people with less
education with less knowledge to Vlad
and Stepanovich such statements are
ludicrous he's a skilled worker and all
he wants is a job without paying bribes
without strings attached if he can't
find that here he might leave for
Germany